the government's scientific advisory
committee sage has released its latest
estimate of the r number that critical
measure of how fast the virus is
spreading
is now between 1.3 and 1.5 more or less
the same as last week
the epidemic is also growing by between
four percent and seven percent
every day now what does that really mean
well the weekly study by the office of
national statistics gives the most
reliable snapshot of the epidemic it
tests random people
whether or not they've had symptoms the
latest data
for the first week of october shows
almost 28
000 people a day were being infected up
from
a little over 17 000 the week before
it estimates that one in 160 people had
the virus
up from one in 240 the previous week
a ryzen infection leads to more hospital
admissions around two to three weeks
later
now the latest government stats show 844
people
have been admitted to the uk hospitals
over a 24-hour period
that's up from 603 a week earlier
but the pressure is building faster in
the hotspot
so in the northwest admissions are up 73
in a week with doctors warning beds will
soon be full
in the northeastern yorkshire they're up
49
and in london they're up by 55 but
elsewhere
the epidemic is in a very different gear
with much lower admission rates
to get the r number below one and shrink
the epidemic
the government needs to reduce the
contact between people
whether that's through its three-tier
system or a circuit breaker
but the office for national statistics
has released another report with some
worrying data
two weeks after the prime minister urged
people to work from home again wherever
possible
to a proportion of people commuting
actually increased
to 65 the highest since lockdown started
easing
at the end of may now the message isn't
getting through
more mixing of people means more spread
of the virus
and that really doesn't bode well for
the future